before I moved to LA I was an attorney
in San Francisco it was a very respected
position it was a beautiful city I had a
great life I had a nice income I was set
and I was deeply comfortable and it
scared the hell out of me
had I stayed I knew for certain about me
not true of all lawyers not true of all
people what have you I knew for me I was
going to wither from the inside but that
was not the right life choice for me on
a soul level on a spirit level not a
role level or a gold level but on a soul
level it was I had to leave I had to
flee I had to run away literally and so
I did and I ran away and I wasn't sure
exactly how it was gonna work out but I
thought I'm gonna go to the far end of
the state to this crazy place called LA
where I knew nobody and I was going to
pursue getting into the film business
because I so love storytelling I'd grown
up inside of books I was a lover of
story and most of my friends and
colleagues and certainly the other
attorneys in the firm I worked at at the
time they all wag their finger at me and
said how can you do that that's so brave
you I or or crazy or something we don't
understand and I said to them it's not
brave it's the opposite it's it's it's
survival
that for me to survive and thrive I
can't stay here this is unsafe for me
and it's unsafe because it's so
comfortable I need to go to this foreign
land called Los Angeles I need to go to
a place where I'm anonymous and know
nobody I need to stretch my limbs I need
to see if I can make it in this very
highly competitive unknown world of MIA
filmmaking because that lights me up
from the inside out I may fail I may
come crawling back on my knees begging
you to take me back
Oh friends of San Francisco but on the
other hand if I don't do it I will never
know and I'll always regret it that's
one version of many many many stories I
could tell about and that's just me
but I've seen it across most of the
people who've been a part of my life
that this thing called the comfort zone
is the most dangerous zip code you can
live in because it's limiting by
definition you get inured you become
habit driven you become you notice less
you become busy with that which is
familiar and you build invisible walls
around that experience that becomes your
longitude and your latitude as opposed
to self defining us an adventure as an
explorer as someone who is going to be a
maverick and do the things that truly
truly express more deeply who you are
and that cannot be the same thing when
you're seventeen as it is when you're
forty as it is when you're 80 we are
designed to evolve we are designed to
change the world changes whether we like
it or not it's good of us to understand
that that's something to be embraced and
it's like our friend it's not our enemy
it's not poison to our spirit it's the
opposite it's an elixir
I've had multiple careers and I don't
think I'm done yet you know and that's
why because I can't predict what my
appetites will be 24 months from now or
five or ten years from now I know what
I'm doing right now is exciting to me
but it always involves exploration it
always involves and and I say that not
as a necessarily as a physical reality
but it's a in an emotional psychological
educational reality you know like who
how can I be a better version of me
that's the job really for all of us in
life how do we become a better version
of ourselves and since we spend a
majority of our waking hours in the
service of this thing we called work and
livelihood boy what a great tapestry to
make sure that what you're doing expands
you